Rumer Willis and Valentin Chmerkovskiy
um you guys are here you're excited you
know your partner has a long history of
dancing in her family can I just want to
show you something real quick just in
case you know I want you to look at this
[Music]
before those who dance with the Stars
your dad worked little right Bruce
Willis right there
I didn't never see that before you
medicine I think I have I just forgot
about it that was yeah I will shout him
out and just say yeah amazing I'm really
proud that's really come across I will
hold it let's not stop there let's not
stop there of course your mom dance -
can we show Dad Liddy we're gonna show
this one okay listen it's a good one
[Music]
can we see that again I take okay easy
that's her mom
so obviously talent is in her was in her
veins how well do you know the Willis
sisters I don't know the Willis sisters
at all we're gonna introduce you to
they'll down this is a throwback picture
of the Willis sisters weird rumor Scout
Tallulah which Willis sister just shaved
her hair into a mohawk the youngest but
I have a mohawk too so that's kind of a
trick question
that's Tallulah which sister walked
around topless in New York City okay cuz
somebody was like keeping me that's mean
it's not that's the sister scout okay
okay all right vow which Willis sister
is this that's rumor okay oh yeah yeah
didn't know that face that phase though
she's already doing this I don't on the
set of strip tease do you remember that
picture okay there was a monkey on set
that day and I remember I was so excited
and what that videos a little bit of the
view again no we're not seeing that
video
her mom again no it's just research for
choreography say that's it yeah there's
gonna be a new you this season now will
that new you be different from this shoe
I want to show and I don't know if
you've seen this rumor oh you got it it
just looks so much worse than silence oh
my god oh man that's you and your
brother Max and it's always worth an
explanation I'll let you explain that
one of these deals you spread in People
magazine like how many people could say
they did that with class and attack then
great hey you dog with my brother what
do you have up your sleeve we're going
to win I mean that's just a fact
before you go give us a little something
I'm gonna get out of the way give us
those are remove the chairs no I'm
moving the chair
come on bow let's go come on
Oh spin until dick alright but that's it
he said we're not gonna give it away
be a lot of fun watching rumor meanwhile
we know how's the man so we don't have
to wish him good luck
you